you know like what their
points reflect the
minimum Maybe
I'm in that discussion did I ever I
never said and you repe are you
Christian once I said yes
firstly maybe I'm mistaken but I saw a
video you long time ago you became
Muslim then I saw video you become
Christian now you return to Islam
But here's the thing, right?  I I when I
after I explored finished Christianity
I came back to Islam,
right?  I talk about Christian you know
what they said to me you was never a
Christian.  You was never really one of
you was never one of us right I was open
to be one I was open to being one of
them.  True.  Okay.
all time and time
churchory of chrtianity of all of that
and my conclusion
is premises is for me for me of the
under the
under this idea that someone completely
innocent is killed for the sins of
others right more intuition
basic moral perception of what is right
and wrong that's going to do you know
god the trinity you know god is one he
three and each the person of the trinity
is fully god two problems one antic it
goes against logic okay 1+ 1+ 1 equ
Number two, it's actually in the Bible.   Okay
.
If the early
Christians, including Jesus, had their first trinity, you would
expect a major controversy with the Jews.
We see complete silence from the contrivances. That's right.
The one who believes in God as the Father
made a
clear distinction between the Father (whom we call Father) and Jesus. So,
those two things you know are that it says Jesus, yes, he was a prophet, he was a messenger. He said, "Only the children of God are truly His." He is not a
hypocrite. I spoke to this one, he is the biggest hypocrite.
I spoke to this one, he hates God and
His Messenger. I said, "Take a verse from the Quran, it is a declaration of innocence." He
couldn't. I
said, "Tell me what the Quran says."
Why do the Shiites read the Quran? Because they
know the Quran. Even the most wicked read this. This is a hypocrite, this is malicious. I
spoke to him, he didn't speak.
This is malicious, this is an infidel. Don't speak to the true Islam. Don't
speak to Abu Bakr al-Siddiq
first, speak
to Islam. May God bless
you, my dear. May God honor you. May God reward you. The Oneness of God.
Islam is pure. There is only one God, the Creator of the heavens
and the earth and what is
between them, based upon His
wisdom, mercy, and justice.
chose amongst us to convey his message
to tell us about our of life and tell us
about himself ag
intellor
second finish God us to show you the
us is the one who send down Islam the we
have naturally inclined is
teaching that's
why you speak
nonmlim for a long
time so every speak to nonmlims about
Islam majority of times I tell you 99%
of them they will never tell you doesn't
make any sense what they say give us a
time I will think about it you know it's
not for  me because you know I do a lot of
sins but they will never tell you
intell yeah yeah that's what I'm saying
that's why always say the people that re
Islam boys down to two factors either is
a psychological factor
factorychological factor
arrogant own deses social factor he
knows accepting is his own family and
friends with him so what he start doing
he will start looking for any excuse and
logical to justify why he stayed or why he he's
continu he's remaining upon his
disbelief so i don't  too many details
this kind of person but i would  say when
i was when i was like before before i
expl religion Right. I wasing many of
those bid
right not closed.  And it got me confused
right it got me confused and I don't get
to some traumatic traumatic experience as
well.
you traumatic experiences say about what I
miss explore a lot of basic and also all
that traumatic experience right those
two those who right so that so that me
thinking right you know is yes I did
have I did have is true to the truth how
so short if I'm not thoroughly explored
all the other religions right let me
just all of them and you know basically
just make a decision right it took me
religion for years for
yearsuding the whole right and
also this point I didn't make it earlier
the Quran Jesus  never claim to be
god never claim to be the son of god he
was only a prop the tr of israel right says
if you look at the western histor today
like but also other professors that
university they say the exact same thing
okay jesus never claim to be
of
primiv isation that that was not during that
time is now being confirmed by secular
research of evidence even about in the
quran when he that they did corrupt
scripture now their own are discovered
many scriptures which for example if you
do read
the l  scriptures
Jesus
even
sources library at home and impossible
Because we know twice in his life and
Andra is
impossible impossible you know that back
but we say that's why you know speaking
Islam has to be based upon knowledge and
certainty bu if I'm certain 100% certain
there is not any room for but you are
standing
speaking to me right now regardless how
many people come along
and regardless how many people come now
listen you speaking to right now he's in
China in a swimming pool swimming I
don't care how many
argumentological arguments try  to bring
because the knowledge that I have about
you I'm speaking to you right now is so certain so that's why Islam knowledge has to be certain you know.
anyone knowledge acton it Muslim
or Jew or Christian that  because why you
know and you still act upon the
knowledge or Christian like Christian
worship God based upon emotion not based
upon knowledge you see soran explain the
rest of
the start with the next
chapter that
book
this
is why
Arab some praise be to
God Alhamdulillah you back
study
because I want straight away I
myself books and myself and I develop it
by myself I kind of myself for
the year I know having Allah for me that way
you have knowledge study why we worship
Allah based upon you
Muslim advice if you don't
give I don't advise come is not the best
place because it is full of doubt and lies
and misconception even myself if you
notice I do take a break from it you know
sometimes you have good people here like
last time two weeks agoamdah sister
became Muslim here so sometimes you have
a nice conversation here but a lot of
times some conversations like
just people about ego you know about
ego show off and you know
deb is debating about is an act of worship
and you should not be doing it to show
people  Allah doing you
step byte praise